I study the dynamics of planetary systems.
I'm an astronomer.
I focus especially on native
and indigenous literatures
of the United States.
I'm a literary scholar.
My research has a lot to do
with the institutions of democracy.
And I'm a political theorist.
Astronomy is this really amazing field
because by looking up and understanding
the stars and the cosmos in this greater
context, it really gives us
a better sense of our own planet
and our place in the universe.
In a lot of ways,
when you step back, it's
a very existential field.
I'm interested academically
in how people relate
to their environments and to their places.
How do places own us?
How do we own places
and belong within them?
One thing we want to do is
we want to understand
how the world that we see is put together.
Political theory helps us to see beyond
what is immediately apparent.
When the job ad came up
for coming to Yale, it was my dream job.
I feel very privileged to have access
to all of the incredible resources.
It just felt like a great place to do
research at this early part of my career
where I knew I'd be supported.
One of the things that I most value
is the students who come from
all over the world, all kinds of backgrounds.
I can now directly support students,
and that is really
the core of my job,
is to uplift other people.
I will ask my students to try to loosen
up performativity
and instead just kind of come into a
sincere approach to the books that we study.
And I also hope they know
that I'm interested
in getting to know them as humans, too.
What you get out of classes at Yale
is going to have a lot to do
with what you put into them.
I think it's just the best place that
I could be starting out my academic career.
It  has really come to feel like home.
I love literature and I hope that
my energy in the classroom is infectious.
My name is Malena Rice.
And I'm an assistant professor
in the Department of Astronomy.
My name is Lloyd Sy.
I'm a new assistant professor of English.
My name is Kevin Elliot.
I am lecturer
in Ethics, Politics and Economics.